MARK DOUGLAS: Hey, everybody.
TODD WOMACK: Hey,
everybody, how are you?
Yay!
Look who we brought you.
Grace Helbig, everyone.
Let her hear it.
MARK DOUGLAS: She's
going to sit here.
TODD WOMACK: Between us.
GRACE HELBIG: I'm
here to fix your car
and answer your questions.
MARK DOUGLAS: I was hoping to
do a big, epic intro, where
I said some of your
stats, and then you
came running in like, "Woo!"
But then, you were like, I
don't want to do that shit.
GRACE HELBIG: No, yeah, that
feels very self-serving.
It feels like I'm here now.
MARK DOUGLAS: You're
supposed to be a Youtuber.
You're supposed to
be like, look at me.
GRACE HELBIG: Well,
that's true, yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, in
case you guys don't know,
Grace Helbig has almost
2 million subscribers
on her YouTube channel,
the Grace Helbig
channel, which is new.
You did that in a week
or something, right?
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, it's
new as of January, 2014,
which is very exciting.
MARK DOUGLAS: Camp Dakota is
one of the first big movies
that YouTubers
just did, and it--
TODD WOMACK: I think it
was the first one, right?
GRACE HELBIG: Well, there
were a couple before.
But we really pride ourselves
on creating a new model that
didn't exist before
for distribution.
MARK DOUGLAS: I mean, Fred.
GRACE HELBIG: Fred, I mean,
who could live up to that?
Basically, Hannah,
Mamrie, and I are just
three Freds at summer camp.
That's how we pitched it.
MARK DOUGLAS: I think I
saw that in the tagline.
You have a pilot
for E that you shot.
GRACE HELBIG: Yes.
MARK DOUGLAS: You know what's
funny is the last time-- I
remember one of the last
times speaking to you,
we were talking about you
doing an appearance on Chelsea
Handler's show and
being nervous about.
GRACE HELBIG: I
was so terrified.
MARK DOUGLAS: And now you're
just going to go in there
and take over for her.
GRACE HELBIG: Well, I don't know
if take over as just quietly
be present there.
Yeah, I'm here also.
It was really terrifying.
But the pilot, I'm
really proud of it.
It has a lot of influences
and elements of new media
and internet.
And I think it's really cool.
And here's hoping
that they pick it up.
TODD WOMACK: Can you
spill any secrets about it
to us, in terms of that?
GRACE HELBIG: I've
been calling it
an introvert's
late-night talk show.
It's a lot like the way
I make my web videos.
It happens in my personal space.
But it's built out
a little bigger,
with some bigger guests
and some bigger shticks,
so that it kind of fits into
the television mold or model.
But it's really infused
with ideas and suggestions
directly from
Twitter, and Tumblr,
and all the internet spaces.
It's cool.
TODD WOMACK: Good answer.
Correct.
GRACE HELBIG: Thank you.
MARK DOUGLAS: Today we're mainly
here to talk about your book.
It's kind of a self-help
book, "Grace's Guide--
the Art of Pretending
to be a Grown-Up."
Seems like you're doing a
pretty good job of pretending.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, no one
knows what they're doing.
MARK DOUGLAS: I get tired when
I think about all the crap
that you do.
Todd and I are not--
I think we're probably
the laziest YouTubers, right?
TODD WOMACK: We're
also on YouTube.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
Did you know that?
We are on YouTube, too.
GRACE HELBIG: That's great.
MARK DOUGLAS: Anybody?
No?
GRACE HELBIG: That's awesome.
MARK DOUGLAS: OK.
They're just trying to
get their work done.
They just thought they'd
come into a quiet space
and get some work done today.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
and they're like,
what's this newly designed
room with curtains?
No.
MARK DOUGLAS: What
made you do this.
Why?
GRACE HELBIG: Why?
I, after I graduated
college, got really obsessed
with self-help, because all
of these self-help books that
were out there seemed
variations of each other.
They all seemed really similar.
They all seemed to give
kind of the same advice.
TODD WOMACK: They're in the
same section at the bookstore.
GRACE HELBIG: They're
in the same section.
It was just like, ugh,
what is this, Nazi Germany?
I hate this.
MARK DOUGLAS: All the self-help
books will get in the van.
GRACE HELBIG: I just
had to get that out
within the first 10 minutes.
Now I'm good.
I wanted to make something
that was a little bit more,
I guess, realistic,
not so holding people
to such high
expectations on life,
because no one knows
what they're doing.
But I've learned some
stuff for myself.
And I really wish that when I
was a teenager or early '20s
that I had someone
kind of telling me
more informational
things about what
happened to them so
I could avoid that.
TODD WOMACK: It's
a really fun book,
because it does-- it's
the first thing that
plugs the gap between a
real self-help book that
would be in these sessions.
MARK DOUGLAS: But then
you have actual nuggets
in there of real things
where-- they kind of sneak up
on you-- where you're
like, oh this is silly.
Oh, well that is actually
really good advice.
GRACE HELBIG:
Deodorant, who knew?
MARK DOUGLAS: Deodorants.
It's just basic health habits.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
it got to a point
where my editor, Lauren,
who's here, she was like,
you've mentioned
diarrhea 11 times.
You really need to
scale this back.
And I was like--
TODD WOMACK: I see there's
actually a note from you to her
in the thank you
at the end, where
you've used it only four times.
Good job, Lauren.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
thank you, Lauren.
That's what an editor
can do for you.
MARK DOUGLAS: But that is
interesting to bring that up,
because-- about
the advice, really.
I think a lot of YouTubers,
and you in particular,
are almost kind of
like an older sister
to a lot of your fanbase.
It tends to be a young fanbase.
So I think this is sort of
a natural kind of thing.
GRACE HELBIG: I didn't expect
to have such a young fanbase.
I tell everyone that the way
I started making videos was
that I was dating a
guy that I thought
was the funniest
guy in the world.
And every time I
created a video,
I just thought would
this one guy laugh at it.
And that 30-year-old
comedy writer
incited an audience
of 16-year-old girls.
So I don't know
how that happened.
MARK DOUGLAS: So it's
really-- he's the brains.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, he's
the brains behind this.
And I'm just the meat puppet.
MARK DOUGLAS: What
happened to him?
GRACE HELBIG: He's succeeding
in the entertainment world.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, OK.
Good for him.
TODD WOMACK: Sounds
very successful.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
he's really great.
TODD WOMACK: Now, who
is your demo for this?
Did you sit down
and write and go
I'm going to make
something for--
GRACE HELBIG: No, I mean
the thing is I didn't think,
I want a 16-year-old girl
to read this and think,
oh, now I know how to do things.
I just kind of wanted to
share my point of view
and what I've learned.
And also, to kind of
start a conversation,
because I don't know how
to do everything, clearly.
And so through doing
YouTube videos,
you get so much feedback
from people constantly.
And the internet
loves to tell you
everything you're doing wrong.
So I kind of now created a
more tangible way for them
to tell me what I'm
doing wrong with my life.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah
this is the thesis
on what you're doing wrong
with your life right here.
TODD WOMACK: You should
have left a little section--
GRACE HELBIG: A
comments section?
TODD WOMACK: --empty.
Yeah, a comments sections.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, with
just a self-addressed,
stamped envelope, and they could
mail me all their comments.
TODD WOMACK: Or just
leave it in the book.
Because sometimes I
wish people would just
type their comments-- a mean
comment-- into the keyboard
and then just go away
and be happy with that.
And then not actually
send it anywhere.
MARK DOUGLAS: And
it disappears, yeah.
Well, one of the
things that is-- I
mean, amongst all of
the fun and goofiness,
I think the one
part that you really
do strive is you really do
have to be a hard worker.
It looks like you're having
a ton of fun all the time.
But one particular part of
the book that I really enjoyed
was where you had
a nervous breakdown
from working at Applebee's
and Dave and Buster's
at the same time.
And you were in a
Target parking lot .
That's such a
suburban nightmare.
GRACE HELBIG:
Yeah, I mean, those
are all my sponsors
for the book.
So I just wanted to put
them all in one story.
MARK DOUGLAS: And then
I threw up at Pizza Hut.
GRACE HELBIG: And then
I used my ibuprofen.
Yeah, I channeled all of
my energy as a young adult
in to working.
I wasn't very social.
But I knew how to work
and to try to make money.
And so that's what I did.
And yeah, one summer I split--
my parents are divorced.
So they live in two different
parts of New Jersey.
So I split my week working at an
Applebee's near my dad's house
and a Dave and Buster's
near my mom's house.
And the Dave and
Buster's sucked a D.
It was so bad, because all
of the cooks in the kitchen
were rehabilitated criminals
that were released from prison.
So there was a security
guard that would walk me--
MARK DOUGLAS: Did
you get harassed
every time you went
to get tater tots.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
exactly, I was like,
can I-- I was like, can
I get a Caesar salad
and for you to never look
at me like that again.
It was really great.
But I used to drive my stepdad's
truck in to work over the Walt
Whitman bridge
into Philadelphia,
work at the Dave and Buster's.
And the security guard
would walk me to my car
at the end of the night.
I hated it so much.
And I didn't know
what I was doing.
And Dave and Buster's,
if you don't know,
is just a miserable place.
It's a half arcade,
half restaurant.
So adults come in and for $10.99
they get ribs and 20 tokens.
And it's just awful.
MARK DOUGLAS: But don't they
have the chocolate waterfall?
GRACE HELBIG: I don't even know.
MARK DOUGLAS: I
thought was where
they had the
chocolate waterfall.
GRACE HELBIG: That was the
name of the chef, yeah.
He was great.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's what
you do after you eat there,
chocolate waterfall.
Oh boy.
Well, speaking of the IBS,
you don't strike me as someone
from New Jersey, what we
think of as New Jersey.
GRACE HELBIG: This
hair, these roots, what?
MARK DOUGLAS: And
you have claimed
to be part white trash at
many points in your life.
And I didn't believe
you until I got
to the cooking section
of your book, which
feels like something that--
like a stoned five-year-old
would make some of this
food, if that's possible.
Can we talk a little bit about
some of your recipes here?
GRACE HELBIG: Sure.
MARK DOUGLAS: Muchachos?
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, it's nachos,
but with macaroni and cheese
instead of just cheese.
I'm obsessed with
the Food Network.
I really, in my mind,
think I'm a great chef.
But then I'm also like,
I can be creative.
And I can appeal to people
that only like mac and cheese
and nachos.
And so I try and
just combine things
that shouldn't be combined.
I think one of the
things in there
is a "palzone", which is a
calzone stuffed with pizza
bagel bites, which, to
me, is just the greatest
form of inception of all time.
MARK DOUGLAS: A lot
of carbs going on.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
it's all carbs.
MARK DOUGLAS: Spam cakes?
GRACE HELBIG: Spam cakes
are just pancakes of spam.
Yeah, it's really--
they're great.
They're delicious.
You can't deny the taste.
MARK DOUGLAS: So
what do you-- do
you just work out constantly?
Or you just shit it all out?
GRACE HELBIG: My
gastrointestinal system
is gone.
No, this kind of came from--
on a lot of my videos,
I make food.
And I make these ridiculous
combinations of stuff.
And I'll always
try them on camera.
And they're delicious.
And then instantly, my stomach
is like, no, please, no more.
And so I-- everything
in moderation.
Yeah.
TODD WOMACK: Good way
to limit the intake.
GRACE HELBIG: Exactly.
MARK DOUGLAS: So your two
best friends, Mamrie Hart
and Hannah Hart, both have shows
about drinking on the internet.
You've mentioned you
have a young fanbase.
We kind of struggle
with this, too.
We just started making stuff
that we thought was funny.
And then you make one Justin
Bieber video, and next thing
you know, you've got
legions of 12-year-old fans.
GRACE HELBIG: That
will murder you.
MARK DOUGLAS: Do you
feel a responsibility
to ever tone it down?
Is there a line that you
have where you're like,
I'd better not cross here.
GRACE HELBIG: I think the reason
that Hannah and Mamrie are
so successful with
their channels,
even though there is such
a presence of alcohol,
is that they're really--
they're actually
really responsible
adults about it.
And they're presenting
it in a real way.
So many people sugar coat
drinking, and social drinking,
and drinking for fun,
or drinking to excess.
And they're
presenting it in a way
that I think is-- you get it.
And it's never-- it doesn't feel
like-- Epic Meal time has built
a brand on total excess,
and total ridiculousness,
and drinking bottles
of Jameson at a time.
And Hannah Hart gets
drunk, and it's just
like watching a
teddy bear do heroin.
You're like, that's so cute.
There's something
sweet about it.
I do think that there is a
responsibility, absolutely.
And someone asked me this at
a book signing the other day,
how's it feel to be a role
model to a lot of young adults?
And I don't-- that will
really stress me out,
if I only think of myself as
a role model to young adults.
So instead, I try and
think, as a human being that
exists in the world that
interacts with adults
of all ages, I just
want to be considered
a nice, respectful person and
hope that other people also
strive for that in their
lives, whether they learn it
from me or from who else.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah, because
the stuff in the book is--
you haven't toned it down too
much to be you have to be--
GRACE HELBIG: And
I think-- yeah,
none of it is specifically--
TODD WOMACK: There's
some funny adult things.
There's funny things--
GRACE HELBIG: It's
just presenting
from my own point of view.
And I think that
Hannah, and Mamrie,
and I became really good
friends because we all
have the same kind of quality of
comedy, of wanting to be nice.
Nothing's ever
really mean-spirited,
or super cutting, or
degrading in any way.
And I think that's kind
of an unspoken rule
we all have amongst each other.
MARK DOUGLAS: I've never
seen you guys throw up
from drinking.
GRACE HELBIG: No
we edit that out.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, I mean,
you guys work so hard.
I mean, there's no way you
could get all the things done
that you're getting
done if you were just
partying all the time.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, if we
were all raging alcoholics,
I don't think that we
would be successful.
MARK DOUGLAS: Remember
when I made that one video
in my kitchen where
I was drinking?
I should have
followed up on that.
GRACE HELBIG: I know.
I mean, Hannah, to
her credit, she's
taken something
that could have been
a very much one-hit wonder.
And she's developed
an entire brand
around it, and a really
respectable brand,
which is so cool.
MARK DOUGLAS: Just
technical stuff, we
have Grace's book in the back.
I don't know if it's
over there or there.
She's signed a
bunch for you guys.
If you want to walk off with
a copy, if you don't have one
yet.
And also, at some
point, we're going
to open it up to questions from
the audience with those two
mics right there.
And if you have a question,
just pop up there.
And we'll recognize, and
you can ask your question
to the microphone.
GRACE HELBIG: I
always feel like it's
a daytime-- a Jerry
Springer, when
there's mics in the audience.
TODD WOMACK: We're going to
bring out your daddy's momma.
GRACE HELBIG: You'd
better get yourself a job.
MARK DOUGLAS: This is the one
to the girl in the coveralls,
you had told him-- this is
an interesting outfit you're
wearing today, coveralls.
TODD WOMACK: Take us through it.
Take us through your
mindset this morning.
MARK DOUGLAS: It works.
GRACE HELBIG: I just want to
be a poster child for the idea
that sometimes you
make choices in life,
and when you reflect
on them later,
you realize they
weren't the best.
TODD WOMACK: But at least
you made those choices.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, you've got
to start by making a choice,
and then later reflect
on it and realize oh,
comfort-wise, great, using a
public restroom-wise, awful.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah,
that's why you
have to have the mic, because
when he was trying to--
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
he couldn't mic me up.
I was like, I'm not
taking this off.
MARK DOUGLAS: It
got awkward quick.
Hold on.
GRACE HELBIG: No,
this is my defense
against any mic man touching me.
It's just coveralls.
Sorry, dude.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well,
there's a little point--
I'm going to get a
little deep here.
There's a point
in the book where
you talk about some
anxiety attacks
you were having, not just
having to do with the fast food
restaurants, but just
from living in New York,
on the subway.
Are you doing all right
back here in New York.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, I'm
repressing right now.
Yeah, no, it's good.
I've always been really hesitant
to talk about personal anxiety
issues, because especially
for being on YouTube,
it's a conversation
that gets talked
about with a lot of people.
And so for me, I
hate being like,
I also am dealing with that.
I'm trendy, too.
I have anxiety.
And so I really didn't want--
MARK DOUGLAS: It's really hard.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
it's really hard.
Sometimes I get sad.
So I really didn't
want to talk about it.
But then I decided,
because I really
have-- I see a psychiatrist.
It got to a point where I wasn't
able to go to my improv shows,
because I wasn't
getting on a subway.
It was just mind
boggling, which is crazy,
because I had lived
here for five years.
And then all of a sudden, I
just couldn't get on a subway
anymore.
And I took some time
to really deal with it.
And so it's one of
those things, where
I can reflect on it now
and realize at that time,
it felt so crazy that I
wanted to talk about it.
Because people that are
having that moment--
I would have really
loved at that moment,
to have someone else
talking about their anxiety
to me, to deflate how
serious it was in my brain.
And I've gone a lot of--
that's probably the chapter,
other than relationship
stuff, that I've
gotten the most
positive feedback on.
Because, here's the thing,
everyone has anxiety.
You're not, I guess,
removed from it.
Everyone has some level of it,
whether they're conscious of it
or not.
And I think it's something
just human and relatable.
TODD WOMACK: Did you start
your YouTube career--
at what stage
during the anxiety--
GRACE HELBIG: I started-- I feel
like when I moved to New York
I had a lot of anxiety
that was totally repressed.
It was just oh, I'm in New York.
MARK DOUGLAS: New York
just amplified it?
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
then all of a sudden,
the glamour of being
in New York wore off.
And the realities of
being in New York,
and there's a homeless man
masturbating on the subway
next to me, became very present.
And I was like, oh, this
is really stressful.
And also YouTube was not
my initial career path.
I was auditioning
for TV and film stuff
while I was making web videos.
And web videos became
my survival job.
It allowed me to not have
to wait tables anymore
in the city.
And I could sit at home and
do that while I auditioned.
So I wasn't really-- I was
doing the hustle of trying
to go to audition, after
audition, after tradition.
And then you get
rejected so many times.
And that adds to anxiety.
And then you just can't get
a moment alone in New York,
no matter how hard you try.
And once you really
actualize that,
it just grates on your brain.
And then who knows?
You're just waking up crying.
MARK DOUGLAS: I started
thinking about it just now.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, sorry guys.
This is a real
comfortable environment.
MARK DOUGLAS: So you were
in the Miss New Jersey
pageant at one point?
I just thought-- there's
not good segue for this.
GRACE HELBIG: Speaking of
anxiety and terrible humans,
let's talk about a beauty
pageant you were in.
MARK DOUGLAS: How old were you?
What year was that?
GRACE HELBIG: So to just
preface this, my parents,
from a very young age,
instilled this crazy idea in me
that I could do anything
that I set my mind to.
So I took that as
a challenge when
I was a sophomore in college.
Well, going back, when
I was in high school,
a girl on my track team
was Miss Teen New Jersey.
And I was like, she can do that?
How'd she do that?
I bet I could do that.
And so when I got to college,
I wasn't a teen anymore,
so I couldn't enter
the teen pageant.
So I entered the Miss
New Jersey pageant.
And it turns out, you don't have
to have any quantifiable skills
to enter a beauty pageant.
You just need $1,200
and to sign off
on a piece of
paper, which I did.
I worked so many shifts at
Applebee's to pay for this.
MARK DOUGLAS: You
footed that yourself?
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, I
paid for it all myself,
because I was an
independent woman.
Yeah, and I didn't tell
anyone that I was doing it.
I just-- I didn't--
which is also weird.
It was all weird.
I don't know what brain I was
living under at that point.
I didn't tell anyone.
Except my boyfriend at the
time, I told very last minute.
And he was like, oh cool.
He didn't come to
support me at all.
And I went, and I bought
a dress for Macy's.
And I had it hanging
in my dorm room.
And as I was leaving, my
roommate saw the dress,
and she was like what
is this dress for?
And I was like, I'm doing the
Miss New Jersey pageant, bye.
And ran out the door and did it.
And I instantly learned that I
was not a beauty pageant-type
person.
And there's very much a type of
person that's very good at it.
And so I got there.
There was a pizza
party for everyone
when we got there,
to elicit friendship.
And I was like uh-uh.
I'm going to go back
up to my hotel room
and watch "Real Housewives."
But it was so strange.
There was an opening
dance number with scarves,
I remember.
And then there was an
evening gown competition,
a bathing suit competition.
And then they move 10
people on to the next round.
And there was an
interview portion.
And I got dressed in
my, what I thought
was my cool business casual
wear, that I got at Ross Dress
for Less.
Literally, I'm awesome.
And then these girls
are getting stitched
in to their handmade
Michael Kors gowns.
MARK DOUGLAS: Were
they like Snookies?
GRACE HELBIG: No, they weren't.
This Polish girl
won, who was amazing.
And you look at
the photos from it,
you're like, oh, very
clearly that girl
has been in beauty
pageants her whole life.
She's standing just
with her shoulders back.
I'm just standing with a
sales rack Macy's dress on
and a fake spray tan.
And I wore a poof in
my hair before Snooki
was a thing in Jersey.
I don't know what
I was thinking.
MARK DOUGLAS: Did
you have a bumpit?
GRACE HELBIG: No, no bumpit.
Yeah, independent woman.
MARK DOUGLAS: You
don't need a bumpit.
It bumps itself.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
it bumped itself.
Where's my extra points?
It's a hilarious
experience, looking back.
I watch "Toddlers in
Tiaras" all the time.
I think beauty pageants
can be really great
for the right type of person.
For me, it's just a
learning experience of nah.
TODD WOMACK: Did you place?
GRACE HELBIG: I
think I got seventh.
TODD WOMACK: You made it
to the ten, all right.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
yeah, I remember--
TODD WOMACK: But
your posture just
wasn't good enough to win it.
GRACE HELBIG: No, my posture,
my clothes, they're like,
maybe you should get an
ironing board sometime.
That might work out for you.
MARK DOUGLAS: Did they ask
you hard hitting questions?
GRACE HELBIG: No, they're
like, so you, and your dad,
and brother have-- you write
down some stuff about yourself
that you think is interesting
that they can talk about.
They're like, so you,
and your brother,
and your dad had done some
half-triathlons together,
which we did at the time.
And I talked all about that.
And then you don't get to
hear, really, anyone else
that's on stage.
But then I found out
that every other girl
talked about the charity
that she was working for.
And I was just like, yeah,
we're not good at swimming.
I talked about that for--
TODD WOMACK: I'm just
running around with my dad.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, literally.
And every other girl was like,
I am big advocate of UNICEF.
And I was like, goddammit.
MARK DOUGLAS: You clearly
didn't take the class
that everyone else had taken.
GRACE HELBIG: No, I missed.
TODD WOMACK: I thought the New
Jersey one would be more like,
so you're in deep to a loan
shark for 200 big ones.
He's threatening to
break your knees.
What do you do?
MARK DOUGLAS: I just
drop my uncle's name,
and he gets the
frick out of Dodge.
GRACE HELBIG: I wish.
TODD WOMACK: Put on my
leather jacket and freak out.
MARK DOUGLAS: In the
book, you actually
said you're not the most
social person in the world.
GRACE HELBIG: No.
MARK DOUGLAS: But
you're a YouTuber.
How does that--
explain yourself.
GRACE HELBIG: Does
that not explain it?
MARK DOUGLAS: I don't know.
TODD WOMACK: Well, no,
I do think that you--
GRACE HELBIG: Have you
ever met a Youtuber-- other
than yourselves?
MARK DOUGLAS: It
does, but it doesn't.
I mean, you have to be very--
GRACE HELBIG: I'm an introvert
by nature, which for so much
of my life, I thought
being an introvert
was a really negative thing.
I thought, oh, it means that
I don't know how to socialize,
which isn't true.
An introvert knows
how to socialize.
It just makes them tired.
MARK DOUGLAS: They
just don't want to.
GRACE HELBIG: Being an
introvert makes you-- I
get really tired in
social situations.
Whereas an extrovert takes
energy in social situations,
loves it.
And so I prefer working alone.
I prefer-- some
of favorite nights
are ones that I've just spent
in by myself with my dog,
drinking and dancing.
TODD WOMACK: And that's
in the book, too.
You'll learn more in
the book, everyone.
GRACE HELBIG: What dance was it?
Buy the book.
TODD WOMACK: I do
think that you're
one of the few people
that has a nice crossover.
You do the YouTube thing,
where people really,
really love your personality.
And you have a lot of
cool things going on
in your channel.
But I've seen you
interview people.
At VidCon, you were
interviewing Chris Hardwick.
And that was a
great conversation.
You guys were very
funny together.
And you actually have the
real, traditional media
skill set as well.
I think you're maybe
one of the first people
to break through that, which
is really good for YouTubers.
GRACE HELBIG: Thanks.
And well, Chris Hardwick has
always been a huge inspiration.
I met him doing
"Attack of the Show."
And right before he started his
whole Nerdist YouTube channel,
we sat down and talked
all about YouTube.
And he is an amazing host.
He's an amazing interviewer.
He really is so fantastic at
building someone up and making
them feel important,
and special, and funny,
and interesting.
And I always thought that
was such a great quality.
MARK DOUGLAS: We
just want to say,
we think you're really
great, by the way.
GRACE HELBIG: You guys.
You guys.
TODD WOMACK: Are you sure you
didn't win that Miss New Jersey
pageant?
GRACE HELBIG: No, next time.
MARK DOUGLAS: OK, sorry.
Go ahead.
GRACE HELBIG: Let's
recount the votes.
MARK DOUGLAS: Chris Hardwick.
GRACE HELBIG: No,
it was really great.
And I think he has
been my inspiration,
because he does just that.
He bridges the gap between
internet personality
and-- having an internet
presence, a really
strong internet
presence, and also
having a very traditional
media presence
that fuses the two together.
But he's a boy, and I'm a girl.
So I'd like to do it for
the female side of things.
MARK DOUGLAS: He's
also-- another thing
he's got going for him is
he's a vampire who never ages.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
what's going on with that?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GRACE HELBIG: Did
you know-- here's
what I've learned about
Chris Hardwick, fun fact.
He was the very first Stacy
Jax in "Rock of Ages."
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, I knew that.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, look it up.
There's a really embarrassingly
great YouTube video
of him singing "Dead or Alive"
in white leather, head to toe.
TODD WOMACK: He's also one of
the tech guys in "Terminator
3," but that's--
GRACE HELBIG: Really?
TODD WOMACK: Does anyone
want to ask a question?
How about we get some--
MARK DOUGLAS: Does anyone have
a Chris Hardwick question?
TODD WOMACK: How about a
Grace question, anybody?
Over there?
Or over there?
They're open.
Don't be shy.
GRACE HELBIG: No pressure.
TODD WOMACK: Don't
be shy-- there's one.
MARK DOUGLAS: Here we go.
Yes.
GRACE HELBIG: Yay, hi.
AUDIENCE: So first
of all, awesome book.
So I have a cousin in
Australia who's a huge fan.
I'm like, autographed copy,
this is going to be great.
And then I flipped to how
to do the walk of shame,
I'm like no I'm not
going to do that.
GRACE HELBIG: What?
MARK DOUGLAS: You're not
going to do the walk of shame?
AUDIENCE: No, I am.
But she's 15.
GRACE HELBIG: But
here's the thing.
You don't set out to
do the walk of shame.
The walk of shame just
happens to you sometimes.
AUDIENCE: I will make
sure to let her know.
GRACE HELBIG: And you've got to
let her know that it exists out
there, because unfortunately,
it can be a walk of fame,
if you do right.
TODD WOMACK: I believe they
call it a walkie in Australia.
AUDIENCE: In Australia, yeah.
TODD WOMACK: Oh, I did
a walkie last night.
MARK DOUGLAS: A
walkabout of shame.
TODD WOMACK: A bit of
a walkabout of shame.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's when
you've got a lot to regret.
TODD WOMACK: But you had
a question for Grace.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
A quick observation
and a question.
So one, could you package up
all the photos you've taken here
and just put them
up on the internet?
Because I could use this
in every single PowerPoint
presentation I make.
Because stock photos suck.
And this is awesome.
GRACE HELBIG: Oh
yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Request.
I will pay cash
money for that, too.
GRACE HELBIG: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: New business model.
GRACE HELBIG: Wow, OK.
I defer you to my
manager, Ken Treusch,
who is sitting in the back
of the audience somewhere.
Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: My
question was actually
related to what you
were talking mind
in terms of mainstream
media and what you're doing.
So vlogging was not a
thing, back in the day.
I don't know if we
called it something else.
But it was not a thing.
And you guys made it a thing.
It's an actual profession.
And a lot of people want
to-- a lot of young kids
want to grow up to
become vloggers.
But you've also transitioned
into this more mainstream world
of filmmaking or, quote unquote,
scripted content to an extent.
I've heard a lot of YouTubers
come up and say, hey,
I'm drawing a line.
Sawyer did this recently,
where he was like,
I'm drawing a line.
I started off as a
blogger, but I really
want to be a filmmaker.
That's how I identify myself.
I've been doing snorting
cinnamon videos,
but that's not who I am.
I'm going to not do those--
he actually said that.
I'm not going to
do those anymore.
Do you have-- are you seeing
more of this around you?
Do you have a point
of view on this?
GRACE HELBIG: I mean,
I think JacksGap
did the same thing recently.
They wanted to be
considered filmmakers
rather than YouTubers.
And I mean, if you really
want to categorize yourself
or identify yourself
with something,
cool, awesome,
more power to you.
I think because media's
changing so much, constantly, ,
that those kind of
categories or identifications
aren't necessarily the
same as they used to be.
I prefer to pioneer into maybe
some sort of hybrid zone.
I think you can do both.
And I think there
is value in both.
And one of the things
that we set out
to do with "Camp Dakota,"
that we're all really proud
was a success, was,
by taking something
like making a film, a
feature length piece of film
but making it personal
the way a vlog is.
My YouTube channel at
the time, Daily Grace,
became a behind the scenes look
every day while I was on set.
I vlogged the
people in the crew.
I vlogged the cast.
I vlogged the entire process
of making a film from start
to finish, to the point that
our boom operator got recognized
in a Starbucks, because
he was in the vlogs.
So when the film came out, the
audience, in my point of view,
has that much more
relationship with that piece.
They knew what it
was like on set.
was like to make it.
And that's why vlogging,
I think is so interesting,
because it allows you this
personal look in to someone's
life that you don't
normally get to see.
And when you see films or
traditional television shows,
it's very presentational
instead of conversational.
And we really
wanted "Camp Dakota"
to be an interactive experience
in a very traditional form.
And that's what I want
with my television show.
That's what I want
with the book.
with anything else
that I do in the future is
to have it be a conversation.
I don't want to be an art
museum that just presents
a bunch of pieces of work, and
asks people to come look at it,
and then that's it.
And they can either
like it or not.
I want to be
standing next to it,
saying what do
you think of this,
and find out what they think.
And if they hate it, they're
out of the art museum.
Thanks.
MARK DOUGLAS: Great answer.
GRACE HELBIG: Thanks.
TODD WOMACK: Here's
one over here.
GRACE HELBIG: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I am on the Creative
Agency team here at Google.
So this is a question
that keeps coming up
to us from agencies
and from clients.
How do we work with YouTube
stars or YouTube influencers?
And how do you work with brands?
Or how do you decide which
brands you might work with?
GRACE HELBIG: Sure.
This happens a lot, because
everyone wants to know,
one, how do you make
money on YouTube?
And a lot of it has to do
with working with brands.
And so it's a huge issue
or a thing to think about.
For me, my most successful
brand partnership
was with Saint Ives.
And it worked because
my parameters are,
is this a brand that I
like, on just a human level,
outside of promoting
them in any way?
Two, is this a brand that makes
sense for my audience to like?
Saint Ives, females,
makes sense.
And three, do they
understand my brand
as much as I understand theirs?
And Saint Ives came
to me with an idea
to promote this new lotion
spray that they had.
And I said, OK, can I make
the dumbest lotion commercial
of all time?
And they said,
yes, within reason.
And so they allowed me, through
collaboration with them,
to make this really
stupid lotion commercial
and to very openly talk about
how I made this stupid lotion
commercial.
And it lived on their
YouTube channel.
And all of the comments
were-- everyone
understood that it
was a commercial.
And they understood because we
weren't trying to hide that it
wasn't.
And they really love
the fact that it
was just out in the open.
The audience is very smart.
And they don't-- they hate
you if you assume that
they're dumb, and they're not
going to know that I'm going
to sneak this Pepsi
in this video,
and they'll have no idea.
So I think for influencers
to work with brands,
the brand has to
respect-- the brand,
obviously, respects themselves.
They built their own brand.
So they have to
respect the influencer
to have created their
brand as strongly as they
think they've created their own.
And so it changes
from person to person,
depending on what
their standards are.
But I think having trust
in the relationship
that the influencer
has with their audience
is huge for a brand to do.
MARK DOUGLAS: Because you
YouTube for-- this generation
is like-- it's like
punk rock, in a way.
It's not as dirty.
But it is definitely
revolutionary.
And they don't want you slipping
something into their food.
And they know.
But if you say-- they
also get that people
need to make a living.
And if you admit,
hey, we're doing this.
You got to enjoy this
video because of Kit Kats.
They're cool with it.
But it's the sneaking it in the
middle of a two minute video,
where they're like,
what the crap?
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
kids are very ornery.
Teenagers love to be
emotional about stuff.
So don't give them any reason
to get upset about anything.
Just be like, I told you.
I told you this was
Kit Kat sponsored.
So you can't get upset
that I didn't tell you.
TODD WOMACK: Now eat
your damn Kit Kat.
MARK DOUGLAS: And the nice
is the other commenters
will be like, she
said that it was--
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, they're
all very self-policing,
which is very-- it's cool.
I don't have to be the bad guy.
They're all shitting on each
other for me, which is great.
MARK DOUGLAS: You can just
walk away from the computer.
Let it happen.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah, that's
a good dynamic to set up.
MARK DOUGLAS: Can we
be in "Camp Dakota 2"?
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, if
it ever existed, sure.
MARK DOUGLAS: I wanted
to pitch some characters.
GRACE HELBIG: Five Freds lost
in the woods, "Camp Dakota 2."
MARK DOUGLAS: One of us could
be the old man who warns them
that the camp has a death curse.
GRACE HELBIG: No,
a lot of people
ask us if we're doing
a "Camp Dakota 2,"
and I don't think we are.
Because "Camp Dakota" was
a really special experience
for all of us.
We want to continue making
other potential long form
pieces of content.
But "Camp Dakota"--
MARK DOUGLAS: About
different camps.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah.
"Camp Blakota."
TODD WOMACK: But that's a thing.
You establish
something on YouTube.
Once it gets popular,
you oftentimes--
MARK DOUGLAS: Do more of that.
TODD WOMACK: --everyone has
to stick to that formula.
You referenced Epic Meal Time.
They're definitely
doing the same thing.
And they've done
a great job at it.
How do you guys feel about that?
GRACE HELBIG: I think
you can't apologize
for trying something
different, I think.
I tell people a
lot, when they're
trying to make their
own YouTube channels,
that your YouTube channel
is like hosting a party.
And so you create all the
party rules for your party.
As long as your guests know
this is a costume party.
Everyone dress up
like blah, blah, blah.
And they come, and they dress
up, and they have a great time.
But if they don't know what
the rules are, and they show up
to your party, and they're
expecting something
that you didn't tell them,
then that's a problem.
If you want to veer off--
Sawyer wants to do more films.
He told his audience, this
is how it's going to be,
letting them all know.
And I think just
being upfront, and not
apologizing for trying
things, is important.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's
something that-- I've
had this writing workshop I've
been doing, writing comedy
for YouTube.
One of your little tips
is actually in there,
where you said that you're
just thinking of the one guy--
GRACE HELBIG: Oh yeah, yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: --that thinks
it's hilarious, and making it
for him basically.
But I always say that you have
to-- it's a lot easier for you
jump to other things if you
let the audience in and let
them know who you are.
Because you do that very well.
I think people will
follow you and Hannah
wherever you want to go.
And it's not about
get drunk more.
They just love Hannah.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, Hannah
has become a personality,
outside of just this
person that gets drunk.
She is a brain with
thoughts and feelings.
Who knew?
She's a human.
MARK DOUGLAS: Who can
talk to the President
the United States without
blinking, or stuttering,
or mumbling.
I was blown away by her.
GRACE HELBIG: I know.
She was so hopped up on that.
Yeah, yeah.
TODD WOMACK: We have
a question over here.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
how much planning you
do for your videos, because
it seems very much like just
you're just having
fun, if you're
doing it with Hannah and Mamrie.
But clearly, you
do a lot of work.
And you have a lot of improv
skills and things like that.
How much of that is pre-planned?
And how much is just
everything's crazy?
GRACE HELBIG: Well,
for years my videos
were-- I would either have--
either an idea would hit me,
in very vague general terms.
And then I would turn my
camera on and just improvise
for 15 minutes.
And then when I
edited it, that's
where I would sort
of put whatever
the story was together.
And that was my
routine of doing that.
And it worked really well.
And I'm finding now that
sometimes that works for me.
And then sometimes
having a little bit more
of a pre-plan, and a
little bit more thought,
and writing some things down,
and organizing my thoughts
is more helpful.
My brain is a lot busier in a
lot of different mediums now.
So I don't have all
of the capacity just
to focus on videos,
like I used to,
which is a bummer sometimes.
So sitting down and
writing things out more
has been more
helpful for me now.
That said, it's still
literally the day before.
I have to edit my video
tonight to put up tomorrow.
And I shot it last night
and wrote it last night.
So it's all still of the moment
kind of things happening.
TODD WOMACK: Do you ever think
about-- I mean obviously,
you're big enough
to hire an editor.
You live in Los
Angeles, where they're
like sidewalks out there.
GRACE HELBIG: Yes.
I've dabbled with
hiring an editor.
And it is still
on my to-do list.
I think a lot of
YouTubers-- and I'm
sure you guys can relate to
this-- are control freaks.
It's your content,
coming from your brain.
MARK DOUGLAS: We just
hover over their shoulder.
TODD WOMACK: It is a very--
you really have to match
styles and sensibilities.
GRACE HELBIG: And
for me, I think
the editing became a huge part
of what my voice is online.
It wasn't just this 10 minute,
unedited thing of me talking.
It was--
MARK DOUGLAS: That's
where you write the thing.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, the
nuances-- and so for me,
it's terrifying.
Because a lot of
times, I'll just
shoot 15 minutes of
complete and utter nonsense
that doesn't make sense.
And for me to be
like, hey stranger.
Here, take this 15
minutes of terrible
and make it into
something cool for me.
TODD WOMACK: 15 more minutes
of my face, here you go.
MARK DOUGLAS: I've heard a
lot of YouTubers struggle
with that.
They get-- even Shay Carl had
an editor for five minutes
and then just was
like, you know what?
Even though I'm a
millionaire now,
I still need to
get those moments.
I don't trust anybody
else with them.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, I mean, I've
started this new podcast that's
half audio and half video.
And there is an editor that
edits the video portions
of those, Because that's a
bigger three camera shoot.
It's a bigger
project unto itself.
But still the
smaller videos-- I do
something called
fry diary, which
is my version of day
in the life vlogging.
It's kind of a week in recap.
And I edit those, because that's
really fun for me to edit.
And I enjoy doing that.
Eventually, if I get myself
into a rhythm or schedule,
an editor could be a good thing.
But for right now-- also my
schedule's all over the place.
Handing someone something at
midnight on a Tuesday night
and saying, I need this uploaded
in eight hours just sounds--
MARK DOUGLAS: You just don't
want to do that to someone.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, there's
a human quality there
that I feel really bad about.
TODD WOMACK: That's
what the money's for.
You would pay that person.
And then they would expect--
GRACE HELBIG: So if anyone wants
to donate to the Kickstarter
to make those editors that
they have get new jobs,
that'd be great.
TODD WOMACK: Do you
have any more questions
from the audience?
I think we're-- we've
got a few more minutes.
MARK DOUGLAS: Here we go.
TODD WOMACK: You have to
walk around it three times.
MARK DOUGLAS: He's going
over there-- there he is.
AUDIENCE: You recently
did a Reddit AMA.
GRACE HELBIG: I did.
That was terrifying.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about that.
I've always wondered, how
do you pick the questions
that you answer?
Because there's questions
being generated every second.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, that
was really overwhelming.
I usually stay away from
Reddit, because Reddit
has torn my butthole apart.
They do not like me.
Redditors have a different
quality of comedy than I do.
And they also only like me
if I'm naked, apparently.
So I learned a lot.
I tried to answer
questions that I might not
have answered other places,
because a lot of the people
that were asking
questions seemed
to have come from me
tweeting about this.
So they might have seen a
lot of these answers before.
So I tried to pick some
things that I haven't really
talked about.
And then, it was mostly just
fast and furious, stream
of consciousness-- the
way I wrote my book,
very stream of
consciousness, just
answering things that I saw that
I had an immediate answer for.
Because there was a lot
of questions coming in,
I wanted to try
and answer as many
as I could in that
period of time,
without spending too
much time on one thing.
And also, because the book
is a more personal piece
of content for me,
trying to answer
the more personal questions
directly connected to it.
Thank you for the question.
So completely random.
TODD WOMACK: This gentleman.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Grace.
Thanks for coming.
GRACE HELBIG: Sure,
thank you for having me.
AUDIENCE: You've
done a great job
of packaging different types
of shows throughout the week.
Can you talk about
the importance
of doing that, labeling
a type of video
a Friday or Saturday thing?
And what is the
importance of having that?
GRACE HELBIG: For a
long time, Daily Grace
was started through a website
called Mydamnchannel.com.
And the videos from 2008 to 2010
lived only a Mydamnchannel.com.
And in 2010, we brought
Daily Grace over to YouTube.
And I sat down with
a development guy
at Mydamnchannel.
And for the first two years,
it was literally every day
waking up, being like,
what is funny then
I can make a video
about for two minutes,
having no structure at all?
And so we sat down before
it launched on YouTube
to create a structure,
to create categories
for each of the days of the
week, so that I at least,
instead of pulling
from anything,
could pull within
these parameters.
And I realized that
that was really helpful
in the growth of the channel,
because people knew--
the same way you watch
television, because you know,
when "30 Rock" was on, it was
going to be on Thursday nights
at 10 o'clock.
You knew exactly when
it was going to happen.
People know if they want
to see me commenting
on comments, that'll
happen Tuesdays.
And so they know what
day they want to tune in.
It was, I think,
for the audience,
a really easy way for them
to consume the content,
because they just knew.
They could see exactly what they
were getting themselves into
and exactly what
they wanted to watch
or what they wanted to avoid.
And I think it's really
helpful for anyone that's
starting a channel,
also for your own brain,
so that you have structure
while you're creating it.
And then they have
structure for consuming it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
GRACE HELBIG: Sure.
TODD WOMACK: We've
one more over here.
AUDIENCE: Speaking
of Daily Grace,
so what went into your
thoughts, switching
from being partnered with a
larger company to starting out
on your own?
And what are the key
differences in your job
that you've experienced
by making that transition?
TODD WOMACK: And can you
explain for the people
don't know what
you actually did?
GRACE HELBIG: Sure, so
my YouTube experience
started with a channel
called Daily Grace,
which was co-created
with a company called
Mydamnchannel.com in 2008.
And like I said, I made
videos for them five days
a week on just their website.
And in 2010, we moved
Daily Grace over
to its own YouTube channel.
And from 2010 to end of
2013, end of last year,
it grew to 2.2
million subscribers.
But I didn't own the content.
All of the content was
owned by Mydamnchannel.
I was paid as an
independent contractor.
So to me--
TODD WOMACK: That damn channel.
GRACE HELBIG: They're great.
MARK DOUGLAS: They're
nice people, actually.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
they're very nice.
So I had no idea that
YouTube could be a job,
and that owning your own
content was even a thing.
It wasn't until I met
people like Hannah
that I started talking to them
about their new-found YouTube
careers and what that entailed.
And that entailed
owning your content,
which was just such a--
MARK DOUGLAS: And maybe a car.
GRACE HELBIG: --and maybe a car,
maybe a brand deal, who knew?
So I felt so-- oh, shit.
I'm in a bad place right now.
And I felt like-- any time I
went to a YouTube convention
or was around YouTube
people, I didn't
feel like an authentic
member of the community.
Numbers to me didn't
really mean anything.
I mean, they were, I guess,
validating on some level.
But I wasn't getting
paid more or wasn't
seeing any financial differences
the way a lot of people were.
And so it was, in
that way, really great
to only have to
focus on the comedy.
And that was it.
That was really nice.
So at the end of 2013,
we couldn't really
reach a mutual negotiation
that worked for both parties.
So I decided to leave
Mydamnchannel and start
my own channel, It's
Grace, on YouTube
at the beginning of this
year, which was amazing.
I felt like I have arrived.
I'm a real member
of YouTube now.
This is so cool.
I own my content.
Wow, this is crazy.
TODD WOMACK: It took six years.
GRACE HELBIG: It took six years.
But I'm here.
And so--
MARK DOUGLAS: It must have been
nice to get that daily word out
of there.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah, yeah,
that was part of it, too.
MARK DOUGLAS: Quarterly Grace.
GRACE HELBIG: Yeah,
I was making--
I started It's Grace trying to
make it as similar as legally
possible as I could
to Daily Grace,
so that the audience
didn't feel.
I mean teenagers, like
I said, are emotional.
They hate change.
So I wanted to be
as-- make it as easy
a transition as
possible for them.
And then I realized, with
everything that's happening,
writing a book and
all this, I couldn't
create the quality
of video that I
wanted to create
five days a week.
So in the beginning of August,
I went down to three videos
a week.
And that was really cool,
because I could do that.
Because I own my channel.
And I was my boss.
And so that was
one of the things
that I learned, starting
this new channel,
is that I have the
creative control.
It's my party.
I get to create the rules.
And it's been really great.
And now, I feel like I'm
in another transitional,
evolutionary period
of my comedy and voice
and going to the next level.
And what is the next thing?
Doing all of this
other media stuff.
It's been really cool.
I don't know what's
going to happen next.
But I'm enjoying it so far.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GRACE HELBIG: Thank you.
TODD WOMACK: I think that is
about the time that we have,
unless you would
like to say anything
to the fine people
assembled here.
GRACE HELBIG: No,
thank you guys for--
TODD WOMACK: The real
reason we brought you here.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's amazing
that you own your content,
by the way, just
on a personal note.
Because you are the
people that helped
invent what this whole thing is.
When I think of quintessential
YouTuber, I think of you.
GRACE HELBIG: Oh,
that's very sweet.
MARK DOUGLAS: And thanks for
coming out and talking to us.
GRACE HELBIG: Thank
you for having me.
Thank you for coming.
TODD WOMACK: Don't forget
forget to get the books.
The books.
There they are.
GRACE HELBIG: They're
signed by my hands.